[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we explain it so you don't
have to this episode will be discussing
the ending of chilling Adventures of
Sabrina part 2 similar to the first
season and Christmas special there's a
lot to unpack from the show and
throughout this video I'll be breaking
down everything that you need to know
about the season and its ending this is
full spoilers ahead so if you haven't
had a chance to watch the show yet and
don't want to know what happens then I
highly recommend that you turn off now
without the way thanks for clicking the
video sit back relax and let's break
down chilling Adventures of Sabrina part
2 chilling Adventures of Sabrina picks
up in the aftermath of the events of
part 1 javi and Sabrina are now broken
up and the titular character has a lot
to deal with after signing her name in
the boob of the beast that was a pretty
life-changing moment for her that comes
full circle by the endings of the second
part and showcases just how much she has
lost due to the choices in the first
season this season is all to do with
identity and in the way that she gained
a new one at the end of part one she
ends up losing it by the end of part two
you so what are the big twists and
reveals of this season well the first
big one centers around Nick scratch ever
since his introduction he's created a
pretty big love triangle between Harvey
himself and Sabrina this season Sabrina
seemed to fall prey head-over-heels for
the character but by the end we learn
that Nick is actually a servant of the
Dark Lord that was sent to make sure
that she submitted to his will it's a
pretty big reveal but it doesn't mean
that Nick is complicit in the whole
thing as it becomes pretty clear that he
has feelings for her and he attempts to
betray Satan and joins her side Nick has
a pretty big role to play going forward
which are getting to later another
shocking twist comes when Sabrina loans
from Satan himself that her father is
not Edward Spellman whilst her mother is
still Diana she actually learns that she
is the child of the Dark Lord Himself
darf a sorry that's the wrong thing I'm
sorry about that anyway all in all this
means that she's not only half human
half witch
she's actually part human part witch and
part Satan thus meaning that she is the
full bearer of the apocalypse pretty
shocking stuff right well while most
would probably embrace her dog destiny
sabrina actually fights against it and
bowser takes satan down no matter what
it takes
sabrina attempts to trick satan by
faking a ceremony of submission to him
with the help of her ants in this they
attempt it in prison satan and it
appears to work for a brief moment
however the antagonist escapes as
apparently no prison can hold him this
doesn't stop the group from trying one
more trick though and madam Satan
manages to briefly hold him for a second
which is when next steps up and
sacrifices themselves nick realizes that
satan can actually be held in a mortal
body and thus allows Satan inside him
he's then laid out unconscious and madam
Satan takes him to Hell where she takes
over the position as queen of the
Delaine because she finally gets what
she wanted which is to rightfully be the
queen of Hell madam Satan restores all
of Sabrina's witch abilities and allows
her to remain free on the surface world
in the end she drops the possession over
Mary Wardwell and wipes her memory so
that she no longer has recollection of
the actions that she carried out in
Greendale though it seems she made to be
dragged back into the fray later on in
the end though Sabrina celebrates though
it's clear that she feels like she's
lost her entire identity after the
reveal of her satanic origins had the
loss of Nick to this and it becomes
apparent that the character can't really
class the season as a win still she
refuses to be defeated and in the end
the group proclaim that they're going to
journey to hell and bring Nick back
obviously this sets up a lot of
possibilities for season 3 I can
definitely see the group turning to hell
to rescue the character but in the
process also having to free Satan once
more the fact that Sabrina now doesn't
really have an identity means that she
will be eager to prove herself I think
going ahead she will carve out a persona
that is a complete opposite to the one
that we saw at the end of season 1 she's
been on a huge arc over the past two
seasons and I think that going forward
she will try and distance herself from
some of the decisions that ultimately
cost her
long run similar to prudence and Ambrose
she is now out on a quest for revenge on
those who wronged her and is willing to
do whatever it takes to get the life
that she deserves without any
compromises overall I had a lot of fun
with part two and the show just seems to
be getting better and better
everything slowly feels like it's
falling into place and the creative team
seemed to be fully adept at dealing with
the assay but the show doesn't always
need to have a happy ending
I can't wait for part three and this is
one of the best second seasons that
Netflix has put out obviously I'd love
to hear your thoughts on part two and
where you hope the show goes in the
future comment below and let me know and
if you enjoyed this video then please
like it and make sure you check out my
full breakdown of Pet Sematary which
would be linked at the end this is the
channel for people who are never missing
television so if that's the kind of
thing you like you need to subscribe to
definition thanks again for taking the
time to watch this
you've been the best and I'll see you
next time take care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]